hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
boilerban Germany Outlaws the insulation
of oil and gas heating systems from next
year
a war on asteroid Turf the call for
eco-friendly gardeners to receive a
council tax cut
aiming for the largest climate protest
ever held in the UK this weekend
Extinction Rebellion pledges to spare
the London Marathon
foreign
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now we begin Today's Show in
Germany where the government is to ban
new oil and gas heating systems from the
beginning of next year in a move driven
by the green party which is part of the
ruling Coalition now currently around
half of all German homes are heated by
natural gas and a quarter by oil but a
bill just approved by Parliament will
mean that all heating systems installed
from January the 1st must be at least 65
based on renewable energy now the
governments in Germany will cover 30
percent of the price of installing new
systems this is amid criticism from
opposition parties over the cost and a
further 10 bonus will be offered to
those who switch before next year's
deadline
well let's speak to our Europe
correspondent Adam Parson this is a big
win for the environmental world but
there is criticism Adam of this scheme
yeah criticism from a broad spectrum
actually because opposition parties have
said that it is going to cost people a
lot of money that's clearly true and
that it is going to put a big burden on
those who can't really uh afford to pay
and I have to say that opinion polls
suggest that the public didn't want this
suggestions that opposition runs as high
as 78 but it is coming and the German
why well the German government says that
it wants to be uh it wants to be running
carbon neutrality it would be hitting
carbon Zero by 2045 and says this is one
of the main things it has to do
effectively saying yes there's going to
be pain but we are going to have to make
difficult decisions as we go forward so
what does this mean it means that from
the 1st of January if you replace uh
your your heating system in your
apartment whether it's new or old you
have to put in place a system that is
least 65 based on renewable energy in
other words that could be solar panels
or heat pumps or a hydrogen boiler now
that is a big deal in a country where
half of the households are running on
gas and another quarter running on
heating oil I'd say heating oil on the
continent of Europe I think is quite a
bit bigger of a presence than it is back
in the United Kingdom and yet when you
put together those fossil fuel emissions
they are enormous heating buildings is
something like a a third of of Germany's
emissions from fossil fuels so this is a
government and as you said with the
greens as part of a three-way Coalition
which is taking this this step and
saying to people that will cover 30
percent of the cost in fact you get a 10
bonus if you do it before the end of
this year now they're estimating it's
going to cost them something like 10
billion euros a year up to 2028 they say
there will be concessions for people on
low income or for older people and yet
going forward ultimately it will be
mandatory to have heating systems to run
entirely on renewable energy now the
opposition have said you are going too
far too fast I think the government have
come up with this compromise it was a
post certainly by someone in the very
pro-business liberal groups uh Olive
Schultz the German Chancellor is having
to do a lot to hold together his
Coalition power has been right at the
Forefront recently because he's phasing
out nuclear energy as well another long
and rather contentious energy policy
behind the German government but the the
bottom line is that here we have the
biggest wealthiest country in the EU
taking a very bold step I suspect that
there will be other nations across the
European Union other Enviro mental
pressure groups looking at this and
saying if Germany can do it why can't
you
okay Adam thank you that's our Europe
corresponded there Adam Parsons well
let's take a look at some of the day's
other climate news now and a new EU
report has found that Europe is warming
at an alarming rate with temperatures
rising at twice the global average now
last Summer's Heat Wave was the hottest
on record for the continent and it led
to the death of more than 20 000 people
and researchers say more droughts is on
the way this summer and only an
acceleration of human efforts to cut
carbon emissions can reverse the trend
schools in two regions of India have
been ordered to close for a week after
temperatures of more than five degrees
above the normal average for this time
of year West Bengal recorded
temperatures of 41 degrees Celsius last
week and scientists say that it could be
linked to climate change or the heat
waves are expected to continue across
the next couple of months putting over a
billion people at risk
which has found Greenland and Antarctic
Ice Sheets are melting more than three
times the rate they were 30 years ago
using 50 different satellite estimates
researchers concluded that Greenland's
melt has gone into hyperdrive in the
last few years and scientists attribute
the speedied up ice sheet lost a
human-caused climate change
eco-friendly gardeners could be given a
cut in their council tax that's
according to scientists at the
University of Sheffield new research
shows that cities have lost more than 50
percent of their green garden space in
the past 20 years with Paving and
plastic grass being identified as key
culprits now the researchers suggest
Financial incentives could be given to
gardeners who keep their Gardens well
stocked with plants
analysis by NatWest of its balance
sheets has found that farmers are
responsible for 19 of carbon emissions
despite only receiving two percent of
loans speaking in a short film made with
the WWF rspb and National Trust Bank
boss Alison Rose pledged to work with
the 40 000 Farmers supported by the bank
to cut their environmental impacts
now it's already calling it the big one
and Extinction Rebellion says it's
aiming to create the largest climate
process ever seen in the UK with four
days of demonstrations beginning
tomorrow it's also a big sporting
weekend ahead of the capital with both
FA Cup semi-finals and the London
Marathon taking place now policing all
26 miles of the marathon route is no
easy job but the race director says
Extinction Rebellion has offered unique
reassurances that it won't seek to
disrupt the event at a news conference
this afternoon the British Runner Emil
caress explained why he thought
protesters shouldn't interfere with the
race
raises so much money for charity and
good causes although I think like the
environment is obviously another good
cause I don't think they should put
themselves
um in front of other good causes and
just sort of respect the the people
raising money for charity this weekend
and then I'm sure other people raising
money for Charlie this weekend will
respect the environmental cause at a
different time
well our Sports correspondent Rob Harris
has more
the organizers of the London Marathon
say they had assurances from Extinction
Rebellion that Sunday's race will not be
disrupted by any protest they've in fact
said they will help to guard the route
of the 26 mile race through the capital
to ensure there are no disruptions by
any protesters at least from their group
but less than a mile from the Finish
around here at Buckingham Palace there
are expected to be environmental process
through the weekend around Parliament
Square it's been called the big one
we'll present an extra challenge for
police as they try to ensure the safety
and security around this huge Marathon
event as well as those protests and it
has been a week when we've seen a new
Spotlight put on how sporting events can
be used by activists to draw attention
to their cause it was last Saturday that
the Grand National was delayed at the
start when the animal rights activists
tried to get onto the course at Aintree
leading to that delayed start then on
Monday at the world Nuka championships
in Sheffield just stop oil protesters
got into the center of the room at The
Crucible and one of them got onto the
green table I managed to put in orange
powder paint onto the surface preventing
the night's snooker action continuing
but the organizer the London Marathon
will be hoping that the assurances that
they've received from Extinction
Rebellion at least means that there will
be no disruption to Sunday's race
and just a reminder that the climate
Show with Tom Heap well it's back this
weekend and this week it's a special
program on the age of climate activism
you can watch it on Saturday and Sunday
at three o'clock and 7 30 in the evening
well thanks for watching that's all from
us today but do join us again on the
daily climate show same time tomorrow 3
30. bye for now
[Music]